hey what's going on everybody you're
watching first we feast hot ones the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings and today I'm joined by Tony Yayo
choo choo choo choo choo choo you knit
and the new EP yeah so now the beasts
pick it up you know how the show works
we don't use some hot food oh are you
gonna ask me some crazy hot questions
you're gonna use some wings with me so
you're here to challenge me challenge
you if you can get through all ten
questions in all ten wings like then
we're gonna give you 30 seconds where
you can just plug away you can plug new
EP plug Instagram all right ever you
want I can handle it got my neck and
sure got my water questions wings let's
bring them up
we can my questions your questions
together
bust them right now I almost start mild
over here that's like no big deal huh
can you rank these rap dances from the
lamest to rest gotcha
schmuck dance stanky leg in lean back
cat daddy yeah yeah it's the bobby
schmurder we can never say his lane
knows that like and shout out to Bobby
smother free bobby schmurder but we got
to put bobby schmurder dance at number
one okay above gonna dance for right now
of da oh okay alright right right now
it's above the you again
yo yo dance always say it's number two
still cuz John Cena
you owe me some money too John Cena his
thanking leg was big man if we go from
lameness I was saying
stinky lady okay look at daddy cat daddy
lean back yeah and up dance money that
was a good question I met very few
number two how cold does it have to be
in order to leave the champion hoodie on
its hanger and instead reach for the
chinchilla fur coat I will say 1520
degrees it's got to be real cold yeah
cuz 40 there might be a little too much
forty fifty degrees you have to
chinchilla on as little too much knowing
yo man
this one yeah yeah nope this nook about
it no it's starting to burn a little bit
now we're going to three and are we
going to three
let me see you first men don't our
kitchen in the front man cuz Chicago you
tough man
what's Eminem's most annoying habit for
every time like we around mu backstage
it's like Taco Bell everywhere shout to
Taco Bell you know sometimes you want
something little different how you doing
on that on that wing you know I think
I'm gonna stop here bro
I think this is weird this is fire like
I'm dying right now I got a really like
it was like a quick sweating everything
a safe where it is digit digit to g-unit
it tapping out give me a couple of
seconds I say it's no joke right I'm
Haitian so we eat you know all kinds of
spicy food but this one right here
brother gotcha yeah but if you keep
going I'm gonna keep going okay all
right yeah me open up another water I
can take a little baby buddy man I
really did
what's the last thing you argued about
with 57 Oh someone that good uh price
next level right there bro yeah
so you gotta tap out
I'll check out you know the safe word
you know the safe word just you did
Tootie you met my god you tonight that's
a foul you got it you know what since I
made it through I'm gonna give you your
30 seconds like I should take this 30
seconds you just want yes yeah did we
just I got a plug yo listen man I don't
know how you did that shout to your dad
what's your dad name Mike Evans shelter
Mike Evans cuz your son just ate the
hottest wings in the world
I got a shout-out the Beast that's out
right now I got a plug out of 50 of
course free go underwear we got a
prog-rock
Evan we got a plug my mixtape coming
soon El Chapo cold corner
um look out for the TV show we're
supposed to be going junus staff my
instagram is Tony Yayo my Twitter sueño
and that's it I guess things are coming
through man mommy look hot food hot
questioners man how did how did you do
that man
you